[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen was heute
im Sport passiert ist das erfahren Sie
von Norbert Lehn einen schön guten Abend
auch von mir und das sind unsere großen
Nachrichten Themen einigen sich die
Ministerpräsidenten mit dem Kanzler es
geht um viel Geld vor allem für die
Versorgung von
Flüchtlingen Israel verstärkt die
Angriffe auf den Gasastreifen Jordanien
wirft Hilfsgüter aus Flugzeugen
ab und Kürzung bei freiwilligen
diiensten Sozialverbände schlagen Alarm
ein Drittel der stellen könnte
wegfallen das große Ring hat begonnen
erst einmal haben sich heute die
ministerpräsidentinnen und Präsidenten
untereinander getroffen zur Stunde
sitzen sie mit dem Kanzler zusammen vor
allem geht's um die Asyl und
Migrationspolitik die Länder wollen mehr
Geld vom Bund und es soll weniger
Flüchtlinge in Deutschland aufgenommen
werden über das Treffen im Kanzleramt
Thomas
reichert es dauert alles viel länger an
diesem Tag erst kurz nach 18 Uhr fahren
die länderschefs beim Kanzler vor schon
ihr Vortreffen hat Stunden länger
gedauert als geplant dabei schien es als
seien sie sich einig waren sie aber
nicht die sogenannten aländer also die
SPD regierten Länder einschließlich
Thüringen sind heute überrascht worden
von umfassenden Änderungs Vorschlägen
der sogenannten bländer also der
unionsregierten Länder und
Baden-Württemberg einig waren sich die
Länder erstmal nur beim Geld in ihrer
Ablehnung dass der bundstatt bislang
3,75 Milliarden im nächsten Jahr nur
noch 1,25 Milliarden für Flüchtlinge
zahlen will sicherlich hätte die B-Seite
sich
noch einige Maßnahmen mehr gewünscht
aber das will ich sehr deutlich sagen
wir haben uns aus meiner Sicht
jedenfalls auf wichtige Punkte äh und
zwar mit allen Ländern und zwar 16 zu0
einigen können die Länder fordern
jährlich 1,25 Milliarden Euro plus
seiner Pauschale von 10500 € für jeden
geflüchteten außerdem soll der Bund
weitere gut 1,4 Milliarden übernehmen
für
Unterkunftskosten atmes System bedeutet
nichts anderes mehr flüchte kommen mehr
Geld weniger kommen weniger Geld und
dass wir uns darauf jetzt heute
verständigen müssen für eine gute
Zukunft für Planbarkeit das halte ich
für außerordentlich wichtig uneinig sind
sich die Länder beim Vorschlag illegal
eingereiste Flüchtlinge in Drittstaaten
zu bringen um dort ihren Asylantrag zu
bearbeiten wir brauchen auch Verabredung
mit Ländern auch auf dem afrikanischen
Kontinent wo unter dem Dach der
Vereinten Nationen rechtssichere
Verfahren laufen und eine ordentliche
Unterbringung gewährleistet ist der Weg
zu einer Einigung ist also lang wie es
aussieht auch länger als der Abend heute
im Kanzler Amt die treffen heute ziehen
sich also Diana Zimmermann aus unserem
hauptstadstudio worauf deutet das hin es
deutet auf Uneinigkeit hin schon unter
den Ministerpräsidenten es war wohl so
dass die CDU
geführten Bundesländer heute neue
Forderungen auf den Tisch geknallt haben
kurz bevor das Treffen losging das hat
die SPD Ministerpräsidenten überrascht
und sie wollten auch nicht mitgehen bei
diesen noch härteren Maßnahmen die die
Union vorschlug zur Begrenzung der
Migration vor allem geht es darum diese
Asylverfahren die in sogenannten
sicheren Drittstaaten abgehalten werden
sollen da ähm sind sich Experten einig
dass sie wohl einiges bringen würden
viele SPD Ministerpräsidenten sehen aber
nicht wie sie umgesetzt werden können
nun sitzen die Ministerpräsidenten 16
leicht verzankt beim Kanzler mit 4er
Stunden Verspätung und wollen von ihm
vor allem eins mehr Geld für die Länder
und die Kommunen die sehr belastet sind
unter der Flüchtlingssituation schon
vorher ahnten alle dass der lang wird
das immerhin ist nun sicher vielen Dank
Diana
Zimmermann sollte es heute zu einer
Einigung kommen hat sie konkrete Folgen
für die Bundesländer und Kommunen denn
sie sind letztlich dafür zuständig
geflüchtete aufzunehmen unterzubringen
und zu versorgen ein Teil der kommun
fühlt sich damit derzeit überfordert
Isabelle de laweger hat sich das in der
häsischen Stadt hombergom genauer
angeschaut
80 Flüchtlinge pro Jahr soll das
häsische Städtchen Homberg aufnehmen die
Bürgermeisterin ist auf der Suche nach
geeigneten Unterkünften in dieser
leerstehenden Bäckerei mitten im Ort
wäre Platz doch das wollten die
Homberger nicht das Problem ist dass die
Wohnverhältnisse hier sehr beengt sind
dass die Leute sich nicht aus dem Weg
gehen können und dass es sich nicht gut
verteilt und das ist etwas was keine
Akzeptanz schafft in der Bevölkerung
hier in diesem Haus leben bereits einige
Ukrainer es gebe noch Platz doch
Flüchtlinge aus anderen Ländern müssten
woanders untergebracht werden um
Konflikte zwischen den Gruppen zu
vermeiden nicht nur das Wohnen auch die
Integration der Flüchtlinge ist eine
echte Herausforderung Beispiel
Kindergarten hier stehen ohnehin schon
70 Kinder auf der Warteliste ältere
Kinder haben Vorrang was wenn
Flüchtlingskinder schneller einen Platz
finden als die
wartenden ich sehe einfach die Gefahr
dass es ein gesellschaftlichen Unfrieden
dann gibt und dass es auf dem Rücken
auch besonders der eingewanderten Kinder
oder der migrationskinder dann auch
ausgetragen wird red fordert mehr Geld
vom Bund für mehr dezentrale Unterkünfte
und für eine gute soziale Integration
die könne aber nur gelingen wenn die
Zahl der Flüchtlinge sinke und planbar
werde das Geld ist ein wichtiger Aspekt
aber das ist nicht der Hauptaspekt der
Hauptaspekt ist dass die Anzahl der
Menschen die zu uns kommen muss so
bemessen sein dass wir die gut managen
können gut managen und integrieren das
mache aber nur Sinn wenn die Flüchtlinge
die nach Homberg kommen auch eine
Bleibeperspektive haben und wenn es im
Laufe des Abends Neuigkeiten aus dem
Kanzleramt gibt und Kanzler Scholz und
die Vertreter der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz für die
Presse treten dann können Sie bei uns
live dabei sein auf ZDF heute Sowi in
der heute
App zum Krieg in N Ost die israelische
Armee ist nach eigenen Angaben im
Gazastreifen entscheidend vorangekommen
demnach haben die Truppen mittlerweile
Gaza Stadt vollständig eingekreist über
eine zentrale Verkehrsachse wollten sie
der Zivilbevölkerung ermöglichen nach
Süden zu fliehen außerdem sagen Israels
Streitkräfte dass sie den Gazastreifen
nun komplett geteilt haben in einen Nord
und einen Südteil Stefan Schlösser
berichtet dutzende Fahrzeuge der
israelischen Armee überqueren die Grenze
zum Gazastreifen und liefern nachschob
das sollen diese Bilder belegen mit
ihrem Vormarsch bis zum Meer haben die
israelischen Truppen den Norden vom
Süden getrennt auch heute ermöglichte
die Armee den Bewohnern Gazas für
mehrere Stunden auf auf einer sicheren
Route in den Süden zu flüchten die 18
Jahre alte mina ist diesen Weg gegangen
und lebt mit ihrer Familie schon seit
Tagen in ihren
Autos wir kamen hierher in der Hoffnung
Sicherheit zu finden aber die existiert
nicht wenn wir schlafen hören wir die
Raketen über unseren Köpfen Schutz und
Sicherheit gibt es nicht allein bei den
Angriffen vergangeneen Nacht sollen mehr
als 200 Menschen ums Leben gekommen sein
so das von der Hamas kontrollierte
Gesundheitsministerium Israel wirfte
Hamas immer wieder vor den Tod von
Zivilisten billigend in Kauf zu nehmen
auf diesen Aufnahmen soll der Eingang zu
einem Tunnel der Hamas zu sehen sein
direkt neben einem
Krankenhaus wir werden diese mörderische
Terrororganisation gegen die wir kämpfen
immer wieder vor der Welt bloßstellen
sie nutzt die Zivilbevölkerung als
menschliche Schutzschilde dennoch werden
wir sie kriegen und jeden Terroristen
eliminieren die humanitäre Situation in
Gaza spitzt sich weiter zu mit in der
Nacht hat die jordanische luftbaffe
dringend benötigte Hilfsgüter für ein
Krankenhaus mit Fallschirmen über den
Gazastreifen abgeworfen die Aktion
erfolgte unter enger Abstimmung mit der
israelischen
Armee un Generalsekretär guteres hat die
Situation im Gazastreifen gerade als
Zitat Krise der Menschheit bezeichnet
und in Tel Aviv ist für uns Katrin
Eigendorf Katrin militärisch sei der
Gasastreifen inzwischen geteilt sagt
Israel was bedeutet das
ja wir sind hier gerade auf einer
Gedenkveranstaltung in Tel Aviv an die
sich mit den Schicksal der entführten
Menschen beschäftigt die noch immer in
Gaza sind um deren Befreiung geht es ja
unter anderem auch bei der Operation der
Bodentruppen in Gaza das israelische
Militär hat den Gazastreifen in einen
Nord und südstreifen eingeteilt weil sie
erreichen wollen dass sich möglichst
viele Zivilisten aus dem Bereich
entfernen nämlich aus nordgaza nach
südgaza gehen damit die nicht zwischen
die Fronten der Kämpfe zwischen
israelischenem Militär und der Hamas
geraten das Militär hat soweit wir hören
Gaza Stadt sozusagen abgeriegelt und was
jetzt bevorsteht ist eine schwierige
Operation das Militär will nämlich in
gazastadt selbst reingehen und dort
versuchen die Infrastruktur der Hamas
Lam zu legen und gleichzeitig auch
versuchen die Geiseln zu befreien danke
schön Katrin Eigendorf aus
Israel in der Ukraine haben russische
Truppen in der Nacht vor allem den Süden
erneut mit Raketen und Kampfdrohnen
angegriffen meldet Kiev einige
Flugkörper seien zwear abgefangen worden
aber in Odessa wurden acht Menschen
verletzt hier wurden Wohnhäuser das
nationale Kunstmuseum und andere
Einrichtungen getroffen auch in der
zurückeroberten Region um die Stadt
Cherson gab es russische
Luftangriffe Anfang Juni hatten das ZDF
und der Spiegel enthüllt das ehemalige
Kampfpiloten der Luftwaffe als Ausbilder
für das chinesische
militärarbeiten jetzt plant die
Ampelkoalition nach Information des ZDF
Hauptstadtstudios die Abwerbung von
Beamten mit sensiblem Wissen zu
erschweren dazu soll zunächst das
Beamtenrecht verschärft werden gleiches
soll dann durch eine Änderung des
soldatengesetzes auch für ehemalige
Angehörige der Bundeswehr wie frühere
Kampfpiloten gelten
der frühere US-Präsident Trump musste
heute in einem Betrugsprozess gegen ihn
erstmals selbst Aussagen und zwar unter
Eid Donald Trump der auch bei der
nächsten Wahl in einem Jahr wieder für
die Republikaner antreten will wird
vorgeworfen über Jahre die
Vermögenswerte seines
immobilienimperiums aufgeblasen zu haben
um an bessere Kredite und Versicherungen
zu kommen vor Gericht räumte er ungenaue
vermögensschätzungen ein bezeichnete
aber das Verfahren als politisch
motiviert der Richter wies Trump
mehrmals an keine Reden zu halten das
sei keine politische Kundgebung das sei
ein
Gerichtssaal ob Kita Klinik oder
Pflegeheim Menschen die ein Freiwilliges
Ökologisches oder soziales Jahr oder den
bundesfreiwilligenienst machen werden
dringend gebraucht doch genau hier will
der Bund kürzen bis
2025 soll rund ein Drittel 113 Millionen
gestrichen werden der Zeit engagieren
sich mehr als 80.000 Menschen in
freiwilligen Diensten es wird befürchtet
dass tausende Stellen wegfallen werden
antoniani berichtet hallo
hallo nur einmal in der Woche kommt
Helga Siebler vor die Haustür sie sitzt
im Rollstuhl und ist auf fremde Hilfe
angewiesen die Freiwilligen von der
Diakonie Baden unterstützen sie die
20-Jährige Lisa gckle als Dienst im
freiwilligen sozialen jah mir macht es
schon sehr Spaß und ich finde es auch
immer schön zu merken wie dankbar die
Leute sind dass es Menschen gibt die
Ihnen helfen für ihren
Freiwilligendienst bekommt sie 450 € im
Monat kürzt der Bund die Mittel werden
wohl viele solche Stellen gestrichen
oder es gibt weniger Geld für die
Freiwilligen das
Bundesfamilienministerium sieht sich
aber gezwungen den Rotstift auch bei
sozialer Betreuung anzusetzen das heißt
sparen auf Kosten der freiwillendienste
das würde auch diese demenzwohngruppe
treffen klagt die Diakonie die Betreuung
der Senioren müsste eingeschränkt werden
wir müssten natürlich auch Stellen
abbauen aber das finde ich ist ein
zweitrangiger Faktor mir geht's uns
geht's als Verband wirklich darum dass
wir für die Gesellschaft für die
Zivilgesellschaft hier uns laut machen
dass das was wir leisten weiterhin
gefördert wird weniger betreuerstellen
das trifft Menschen die auf Hilfe
angewiesen sind Helga Siebler hat Angst
dass ihr Spaziergang gestrichen wird
schlimm weil da vereinsam wir dann ich
kann ja nicht ganz Tag Fernseher schauen
oder musikche und das ist halt einfach
was W sie unterstützt deshalb wie mehr
als 100.000 andere eine Petition gegen
die Kürzungen in der kommenden Woche
debattiert der Bundestag über den
Haushalt und auch über die Zuschüsse für
die Freiwilligen
Dienste nach dem unblutigen Ende der
geiselnah auf dem Hamburger Flughafen
ist man dort zum Normalbetrieb
zurückgekehrt esib B aber Fragen offen
etwa die ob die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen des
Airports ausreichend waren und ob es
auch auf anderen Flughäfen passieren
könnte dass ein unbefugtes Fahrzeug aufs
Vorfeld fährt über die aktuellen
Sicherheitskonzepte und mögliche
Schwachstellen berichtet Sven
ren heute Mittag bekam Tour 43g am
Hamburger Flughafen neue Schranken durch
eben diese nordzufahrt konnte der
35-jährige Mann am Samstag fahren
offensichtlich waren das Eiserne Tor
offen und die plastikschranken kein
Hindernis weitere Einrichtungen zum
Stoppen von Fahrzeugen gibt es nicht das
wird sich vermutlich nun ändern ja ist
so dass wir natürlich immer ein Mix
haben aus technischen Maßnahmen und auch
Menschen vor Ort das ist so am Flughafen
das ist unser Sicherheitskonzept und
jetzt werden wir bauliche Maßnahmen
tatsächlich vornehmen um den Zugang zum
Sicherheitsbereich zu verstärken und wir
werden weiter natürlich mit den Behörden
auch das Konzept noch mal schauen
Deutschlands Flughäfen sind
hauptsächlich mit Zäunen und Toren
gesichert keine überwindbaren
Hindernisse wie auch Aktivisten der
letzten Generation in Berlin und Hamburg
zeigten auch Drohnen bringen den
Luftverkehr zum Erliegen solche
abfangsysteme sind noch in der
Erprobungsphase und teuer Sicherheit an
Flughäfen kostet Geld es ist nicht neu
aber es ist sicherlich auch wichtig das
jetzt zu bewerten kann man so
weiterarbeiten wie bisher oder geht es
darum mehr vielleicht auch Beton zu
verbauen und gleichzeitig den
Flughafenbetrieb nicht nur
wirtschaftlich sondern operativ am
Laufen zu halten Versorgungsfahrzeuge
Rettungswagen Lieferverkehr alle müssen
hier durch mehr Sicherheitskontrollen
bedeuten auch mehr Wartezeit auch das
kostet wieder mehr Geld nach diesem
Wochenende am Hamburger Flughafen aber
wird wohl mehr
passieren er war einer der bekanntesten
Fernsehmoderatoren Journalisten und
Showmaster Hans Meiser ist gestorben
seine nachmittagstalkshow in den 90er
Jahren war die erste derartige Sendung
im deutschen Fernsehen
manchmal auf Kall aus immer schrill für
RTL präsentierte er weitere
Unterhaltungsformate und die Nachrichten
Hans Meiser starb an Herzversagen er
wurde 77 Jahre
alt und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport zur
Fußball Champions League norberter
trifft Dortmund ja morgen Abend auf
Newcastle ein wichtiges ein schweres
Spiel wichtig weil ein BVBs in der
Hammergruppe f die Chance aus
Weiterkommen waren würde ja und schwer
weil der weil der Borussia die blamable
Heimschlappe vom Samstag gegen die
Bayern wohl noch in den Knochen und
Köpfen stecken
dürfte besondere Spiele verlangen
besondere Vorbereitungen beim letzten
Mal muss da beim BVB was schief gelaufen
sein denn die Bayern mit dem
dreierpacker Harry Kane haben die
brorussia beim 4-0 in Dortmund auf den
Rasen der Tatsachen zurückgeholt das war
erstmal zu verdauen da sind wir sehr
offen und sehr ehrlich miteinander
umgegangen um dann den Haken drunter
zusetzen um dann den Montag den heutigen
Tag dafür zu nutzen um das Ganze wieder
nach vorne zu den Blick nach vorne zu
wenden der Blick zurück hilft aber auch
beim Hinspiel in Newcastle sorgte
felixcher für den ersten saisonseg in
der Champions League nach dem 04 vom
Samstag soll nicht der Eindruck
entstehen man habe die großen Spiele
nicht im Griff ich er mich auch an eure
Schlagzeilen vor dem Spiel in Newcastle
wie richtungsweisen dieses Spiel da ist
deshalb war es auch ein richtig großes
und wichtiges Spiel für uns und da haben
wir gezeigt dass wir auch das gut
bewältigen können das Team schien beim
Training heute auch schon wieder schön
im Gleichgewicht zu sein Newcastle kann
kommen zu Fußball be Bundesliga da hat
gestern abend Aufsteiger Heidenheim den
VfB Stuttgart mit 2:0 besiegt ein
spannendes intensives Würtemberg Derby
das erst in der Schlussphase entschieden
wurde dieses Tor von Heidenheim zwingt
Stuttgart endgültig in die Knie zweite
li Niederlage für den VfB nacheinander
Höhenflug gestoppt natürlich hat der VfB
auch zwei drei hochkaräer gehabt aber
wir vielleicht noch ein2 sogar mehr ohne
den verletzten Tor Garanten seruass sind
Tore Mangelware Stuttgart zwar mit viel
Druck aber auch vielen fatalen Chancen
auch dieser ELER in der 57 Minute der
Anfang vom Stuttgarter Ende beginnt aber
erst in der 70 Minute Ecke und Jan
schöner gelingt das 1:0 in der
Nachspielzeit erhöht Tim kleindiienst
dann zum 2:0 Endstand Heidenheim beendet
die Serie von vier
Pflichtspielniederlagen Stuttgart bleibt
auf Tabellenplatz 3 jo alle Tore alle
Höhepunkte des Zeh Spieltags zu sehen
bei ZDF heute.de und in der ZF heute App
zip toop danke Norbert
was passiert wenn Alltag auf skuriles
trifft hier ein besonders hübsches
Beispiel im polnischen Lodge wurde eine
Straße neu betoniert alle Anwohnerinnen
und Anwohner waren gewarnt nur einer hat
verschlafen weil aber Zeit Geld ist und
der Beton angerührt war werkelten die
Arbeiter einfach ums Auto herum
Abschleppen ging juristisch nicht sagt
die Polizei am Ende verschwand das
einbetonierte Auto über Nacht wie das
weiß nur der Besitzer
das oft ungemütliche Herbstwetter setzt
sich fort mehr dazu gleich von östtin
terle das heute journal läuft um 21:45
mit Marietta Slomka machen sie es
[Musik]
gut schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das unruhige
Herbstwetter wter setzt sich weiter fort
also Regen und Wind begleiten uns auch
in den nächsten Tagen aber es gibt auch
trockene Abschnitte z.B im Norden
Deutschlands das sehen Sie hier z.B
morgen dann hier in der Nordhälfte
deutlich weniger blau Flecken wie im
Süden das bedeutet es gibt weniger Regen
im Norden und das schon in der Nacht
ganz im Norden allerdings auch einzelne
Gewitter im Süden ziehen hier Schauer
durch die Temperaturen gehen zurück auf
0° am Alpenrand und 9° an der Nordsee
das ist die Temperatur Spanne morgen
dann ziehen neue Schauer von Südwesten
her auf nach Norden ist es deutlich
Trockner als im Süden ja Osten zeigt
sich mal die Sonne auch Richtung Bayern
hier einzelne Sonnenflecken durchaus
dabei ganz im Norden gibt es aber auch
wieder Gewitter bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 13° im Osten
Deutschlands und 7° z.B hier Richtung
Vogtland die nächsten Tage ja erst
einmal Mittwoch noch relativ trocken
erst zum Abend kommen hier im Nordwesten
neue Schauer auf S 12° Donnerstag und
Freitag deutlich durchwachsener mit
Regen und etwas kühler schönen Abend